foreign
there's a UK prison
um You probably heard about this already
there's um they had to fire 18 guards
all women
because they were hooking up with the
prison I was tired they're probably
getting commissary 18 female guards
that's
it yeah dude they're probably throwing
it down oh they do that do you think
they're they are just like dude this guy
this prison has the hottest man they're
like and then they all told their
friends yeah yo there's so many hot
dudes in this game I hover for each
other dude who's gonna bone better than
a guy who's locked up bro who's gonna
throw down hard yeah because they're
just like I haven't seen [__] in like
10 years well how long do they last
though
that's what you're thinking
look these guys in prison they take
wallets and put them in the microwave
and try to [__] them you better believe
having some fresh push throwing at you
is going to be mind-bending never heard
of that guys no
they take an old leather wallet they
slap it against the wall a couple a
couple dozens loosen it up yeah dude you
gotta break it in you're gonna Shawshank
yeah dude so there's um so there's a
crazy thing though it's not just that
they're hooking up with them that's like
one thing right okay
one of the main reasons is a problem is
they're doing them all kinds of favors
they're smuggling them they're in love
they're in love yeah it's an exchange
bro it's not just sex yeah it's not
they'll they're get they're uh they're
getting them phones they're uh um yeah
they're also getting caught because all
of their chat logs they're like talking
to them via those phones so now they
have like WhatsApp records all from the
same prison same prison yeah really
snitched it was a guy I guarantee it as
a jealous guard guy jealous guard guy
yeah yeah you're probably right these
girls won't [__] me but so [__] all
these guys
I'm a good guy well that's also that's
what happens all the time like even with
that one girl who was uh having sex with
the cops in her Department yeah that
ultimately got uncovered because one guy
wasn't getting any got mad that's how it
always goes [__] time
yeah that's what happens give the guy a
handy or something
[Laughter]
dude you have to pay the tags yeah the
incels ruin everything yeah they do so
they just got fired they got fired all
of them
a lot of interviews do they visit them
and it got replaced by strong Burly men
yeah and all the jail guys were like oh
maybe girls isn't that kind of sad
though to think like what if you you're
a person right and you're in love with
this guard and you have a thing with her
and then she gets fired over it and then
she stops coming around and you're like
I knew it wasn't real it was just
because I was a prisoner and you were a
guard yeah you fetish that is me you
fetishized me the Magic's brother you're
like a bad boy mentally and physically
are you gonna talk to me on the outside
yeah like what if it's not the same mean
I knew she wouldn't like me for me out
on the outside to now she's back to
being a regular civilian but she wants a
little Butch so it's okay yeah the
sexiness is gone man
how would you think they were [__] in
the jails they were yeah they were and
they were and plus they were recording
uh like their intimate times or cocky
not always kiss not always like sex with
kissing or there was like selfies kiss
yeah or there was like uh wallpapers on
your phone like backgrounds like stupid
it was real it was real it was real love
all of them they're taking selfies
together it's romantic we failed them
guys the prison system fails them that's
pretty tight yeah what about these poor
abused men too yeah there's no reason to
talk about that but I will yeah what's
their story that's true are they okay
yeah they were used the women in power
just totally took advantage of these
four innocent guys when they get out
they're probably gonna go after the
girls
oh like like in a bad way sure I don't
know like in one of these ones like what
if like
oh my God she gets fired he's like okay
six years I can do this wait for me baby
he gets out in six years tracks are now
sees her with someone else we think it's
gonna happen and then someone else was
someone who got out earlier
cellmate but the correction system
worked on him so he says oh good day all
good good day because they're gentlemen
in the UK exactly the correction system
they do a little yeah she gets a curtsy
you know man
it's a little confusing here too because
they say that that um that jail is one
of the cushiest where uh the cells don't
have bars on the Windows they have
actual bathrooms in the cell and their
[__] being thrown at you 24 7 365.
that's where I'm trying to go and the
inmates have TVs laptops and what kind
of tail is oh man that's not General
that sounds like some minimum security
daycare yeah yeah it's like a a um I
liquidated billions of dollars of
depositors at a bank I'm like oh that's
not that big it sounds like soft
security over here dang you can watch
HBO Max and that's it maybe that's why
they were getting so many girls in there
it says that last year there was a uh
there was a girl named Emily Watson it
was a guard and she had to do one year
in jail for giving head to a prisoner
and then what if it's the same jail that
she gave head to so she's like no I'm
gonna be in with my lovers yeah she's
all adult throw me in here she gave head
to a prisoner yeah
she should get an award what if what if
her what if these women keeping these
guys nutted all the time made them less
violent yeah because it's hard to keep
being a killer when you're getting laid
but then you're in jail you're not gonna
be a killer in jail right
I mean they're they're fighting and
killing each other yeah okay yeah
there's jail riots what if they were the
glue like they were like really just no
they're too busy watching TV and like
looking out their window without the
bars there
but the Oculus Rift
because these guys might be like
Financial criminals like they're
billionaires and they're all like high
level dudes yeah I wish I could see what
they looked like because like they have
pictures and some like high-level
criminal dude yeah like Jeffrey Epstein
but he has to [__] like a 28 year old
and he's like God damn it he's like what
a drag sucks
you're gonna [__] these old ladies it's
like filing for transfers all day oh
this is torture oh the [__] I gotta pull
up put up with like why do I have to do
this ugh but that must be like next
level uh I guess Riz in a way if you can
actually convince a guard to
have sex he said it was 18. that's a lot
bro are the are the ladies pretty cool
everyone knew you tell me man let's see
it's like that's like a middle school
dude it's like a high school because
like at the same time if you're a good
looking guy and she's lonely and like
and she's a guard like she doesn't like
that yeah sociopath very manipulative
like you could [__] fool any of them
why do they leave the three I don't know
it's like even though there's 18 of them
it just keeps showing these same three
so I guess take them as the uh standard
yes standard and tell me if you think
hot guards huh I did not picture them to
be guards that's pretty pretty nice yeah
pretty nice situation I mean they don't
have their makeup and everything on but
like yeah how are they guards for like
big prisoners that's what I'm saying I
mean yeah I mean when you're taking a
soap wrapper and you're throwing in the
microwave and you're trying to make love
to it
[Music]
I mean this is like maybe the upgrade of
the [__] Center he's a velcro wallet
yeah
they're like in prison they're like tens
bro yeah dude they're above 10. you're
taking Heaven you're taking a [__]
Lifesavers
[Music]
and you're looking at it like I'm gonna
somehow make love to this ramen noodles
yeah if they're pill if they're pulling
out a [__] Pringles container and
throwing socks in there to [__] it like
Yep they're spitting in it for 40
[__] hours
to shove their [__] into it and then all
of a sudden there's a backlit light and
these [__] Heavenly Beauties don't
want
you can't believe your luck they're all
colluding with each other to suck your
dick but take turns sucking your [__]
dick you can't believe your luck come on
bro I murdered a guide I must have gone
to heaven
what are the chances I know right only
in America wow this is better than
escaping
how do you feel about
like
you could go to prison but be like I'm
trans and I could go to a male prison I
have to try it I don't get it some
people it it happens there's guys in all
girl prisons
yeah no they're trans but it is but
they're no but it's they're trans and
it's called a loophole and they gotta
try it you gotta at least yeah yeah
that's actually happening right now I
read some [__] that's right only if you
are a trans woman you gotta try it yeah
um yeah well hold on yeah hold on no
you're right yeah oh wait are you right
put me in the Czech prison so put a
dress on me because men's prisons are
infinitely way more dangerous correct
way more dangerous but what if you're
gay yeah then it's hard to danger danger
laughs
[Music]